yeah welcome to this video I'm playing
five minute blitz again against them
Grandmaster from Russia under a DVR kin
rated 252 549 ok so let's play some
ready style and see what we get yeah
instead playing a very solid set up with
c65 and black has excellent chances to
to equalize in these setups especially
if you know of this capture on f3 this
leads to a very very solid black
position Black has got no no bad piece
this is so very helpful you don't suffer
from a bed on c8 bishop for example have
exchanged that and no it said bishop on
on good squares yeah why does got two
bishops this is his main hope long-term
to to get something but it's very young
very little to to play form as the
structure as some is so one symmetrical
yeah one ideas to go before but he's got
a five so it's not um clear that this
really am gives a white zone much queen
bee three you can play 9500 so it's also
not not great yeah I'm not quite sure
how to how to continue here
efore guess one possibility trying to
open it up but you can answer D form of
course okay I'm not the kind of player
wants to sit still and do nothing
probably before isn't so great but I
really couldn't go for some las a move
like h3 just passing I don't really see
am a good constructive plan this is
actually a little bit of a problem line
for white in this opening it's a it's
very yeah how to how to call it um yeah
bit of without any big prospects yeah of
course I saw I saw 94 I only thought
that it maybe isn't so great but is
threatening 92 this is a problem and not
be five okay I really hope that some
[ __ ] there's nowhere nowhere technical
disaster coming here can easily happen
no night confusion somehow I'm somehow
this is scott numb bit tactical gay
threaten 92 already so this is why i
played rook you want to take with the
rook my idea is to go III and exchange
stuff
okay em to serve this attacks um this
attacks on d3 okay I want to get out of
this diagonal this really is making me
nervous but he's cut quite nicely placed
on nights now here maybe this isn't
really a big issue but it looks am it
looks really am annoying what about f43
sss is terribly weakening maybe it is i
want to get rid of those nights it's
really a it's really annoying at least
he's spending sometimes the only thing
that is slightly comforting here so III
now it's probably going to be five but
this is still the the move tool to go so
deform not the move you want to play
with okay let's
let's close this this position black
obviously has a good position it's it's
clear deform it's not the move you you
do you want to play but what them what
else should should have should have done
so just very him very uncomfortable
position with this somewhat bad bishop
on d to maybe I can try to get to get
rid of it not not nice fitting okay but
at least on 96 second I can take this
you cannot go to you fall so easily
okay you can think about taking with the
pawn opening up the sum this long
diagonal yeah Queen Queen can maybe
enter here some somewhere but then I try
to play Queenie form the zone really
what would help me activating pieces I
actually think the worst is over maybe
this is the wrong assessment but I can
play even g-form maybe yeah i think this
position is okay now maybe you should
have taken with the Queen 97 g 5 wins
Peace night age 6 maybe 9860 came so i
can couldn't go here because of the fog
so no g4 is hanging here come on
I didn't consider this move this is sam
this is a bit bit annoying I thought him
he must retreat but of course this was
just better yeah just grabs all the
pawns yep okay yeah bishop you one
really irritated me and this also means
that King III was just bad I don't know
it feels like shouldn't I be okay here I
of course I was worth before but I
cannot believe that putting pieces on h4
day and age 6 can be really good Queen
f3 yeah i'm just here after the game and
in the game what but this was so what's
the problem I didn't see this move is
simply out only am considered retreats I
need to go here probably done then the
night is just just bad on age 6
Queen d8 is what the computer suggesting
maybe intending a five at some point
also just covering this piece yeah
computer assessment is equal of course I
was worse before so um this was also
responsible for my for my time for my
time issue but it was time wise it was
ok again here but um yeah g4 is also
right I think so yeah here I overlooked
Bishop you one and this really gives
black did one touch again yeah an
interesting game thanks for watching